[Music]
a rare invitation
to friday prayers
in tehran's most conservative shrine
a high-ranking commander from iran's
revolutionary guard
is addressing the faithful
a western crew filming this here is
almost unheard of
commander nasa is just back from syria's
civil war
where he says iranians are fighting
daesh or islamic state
before it can attack them at home
[Applause]
death to america death to britain death
to israel and saudi arabia
before a kalashnikov clutching cleric
leads prayers
in a week's filming we were given
unprecedented access to a country
that remains deeply conservative
but is also undergoing profound change
after prayers a rally women protesting
to support the islamic head scarf
young people chanting again against the
west but this time with impeccable
politeness
apologizing for it too you shout down
with america
down with england yeah don't you like
america don't you like england no not
that much we
love iran of course
uh sorry where are you from we're from
england
oh yeah sorry actually people
are here you know to show their
probably loathe uh against israel
and the us and also england they're
shouting down with england is that right
uh yeah they are but do you like america
uh
yeah why not you know i like people
you know it doesn't matter where they're
from
makes feelings then about the outside
world in a country
that is beginning to open up
on the outskirts of tehran the tomb of
ayatollah khomeini
who led iran's islamic revolution and
began its isolation from the west
almost four decades on he remains
revered by tens of millions
the revolutionary religious brand of
government he began
still holds sway it's the iran we've
known
for almost 40 years
[Applause]
[Music]
this isn't if you think iran's all
ayatollahs and headscarves
think again in a brand new shopping mall
iranians can indulge a love of consumer
goods
with many of the brands we're familiar
with available here
in an alternative 21st century reality
here they're happy to talk about their
love of the west
you like britain and america yes and
iranians used to say britain was
little satan and america was big satan
has that changed now
it's a political slogan but
my people love
western culture uh my friends
love america i love greetings
he loves london
so he loves london yes and you all like
america
and is it is it safe in iran to talk
about politics yet
yes because
she says you are lying but i say uh it's
safe to say
our favorite politics uh conditions but
i'm not activists if you'll be activists
maybe the engine if you're an activist
it's dangerous yes
and when i travel to iran i can see it
everything has changed
especially young people and situations
is life getting better here do you think
yes i think yes absolutely yes
more freedom for young people
up to a point human rights groups have
serious concerns about civil liberties
in iran
but one strict rules about clothes and
behavior are being relaxed
in the park another surprise
[Applause]
it's hard to imagine anything more
western than a skatepark
[Applause]
iran's government is building lots of
them apart from the headscarves
you could be anywhere in america
we talked to irfan rastami soldier
turned skateboarder
he doesn't like everything he hears
about the west
for me if i was if i was leaving united
states
i was kind of afraid more than era why
because i think like nowadays police
killing black people
you know and i've heard from many
friends iranian friends who lives in the
united states that they're
you guys even living more freedom than
americans see because
for me i'm not really looking freedom as
like going club drinking you know
i think freedom is
uh when you see your life you are okay
with it you know
you just smile
we left tehran past salt lakes heading
south for the city of com
the spiritual heart of iran
millions come here to worship from
across the muslim world
and an important shia tomb under
minarets
and a burning desert sun
here a hundred thousand religious
students study islamic doctrine
we met one of the city's most senior
clerics ayatollah maliki told me
there were good things about the west
like its work ethic and technology
but that's not what it sends abroad
it seems like the u.s is doing this on
purpose not to pass
on the good parts of the culture and
technology but just the decadent part of
its culture
to keep the use of the third world under
control
to keep its superpower status
iran is a country of bewildering
contrast
where the old collides with the new
where a religion that goes back
centuries is worshipped alongside modern
material devotions
there's no doubt many iranians want
progress and their country
to open up more they voted for a
government that's done a deal with the
west
america europe and others said they
would lift sanctions on iran
and iran said it would scrap much of its
nuclear programme
but a year on and many iranians say they
are disappointed
and feeling let down by the west
hamad banadinejad was one of the iranian
officials who negotiated the deal a year
later he's now helping defend it
as public disenchantment grows
press conferences begin here with the
national anthem
which is always followed by a prayer
before questioning can begin
mr banadinejad answered more than two
hours of questions
many of them skeptical afterwards
admitting to us
the agreement is facing serious problems
you had a lot of questions today
do you think that there is the deal is
in some doubts now in iran
one year on no because you have a lot of
questions it was a two-hour press
conference
sure are there doubts in the iranian
government that this will work now
no there is no doubt it's working well
but there are
problems there are impediments obstacles
that we are
in fact determined and all of us with
the good cooperation from our colleagues
to to overcome them and dissolve them
how significant are those obstacles do
you think
are they serious obstacles they are
serious because
it's not only the question of the
subject matters but the question of the
commitments of the other side to be
complying with their obligations
dive into the grand bazaar of tehran and
you'll be told the hopes of a year ago
are melting away lifted sanctions aren't
being felt
much here they say carpet seller medi
gazvinian says the grand bargain
iran struck with the west is not being
honored by the other side
so the deal with america yeah has that
helped your business
a little bit not so much but it was a
uh just a small hope you know for future
but
until no no happens not much difference
no
not much difference opinion polls say
the nuclear deal is increasingly
unpopular with iranians
analysts close to hardliners in
government say western leaders need to
understand
what's at stake i think what they should
realize
is that if if this agreement fails
iran will go back to its previous
uh nuclear policy of expanding the
nuclear policy
and some people in washington are not
going to like that
the question of military confrontation
will be on the table again and that's
not really good for
anyone that's not good for iran that's
not good for this part of the world we
already have too many wars going
on and then this is not good for the
other side either
outside the bazaar furious trading and
gold futures on the black market
a kind of underground iranian wall
street
and a sense of the country's untapped
economic potential
delegations hoping to make the most of
it are brought here
a tower soaring above tehran a steady
stream
are coming to enjoy the view and do
business here
but not the number iran had
the us britain and europe remain
critical of iran
its support of groups they regard as
terrorists its ballistic missile test
and poor human rights record
but both sides had agreed to work
towards ending years of animosity
many here clearly still want closer ties
there's an obvious yearning for more
contact with the outside world
but the window of opportunity may soon
be closing
dominic waghorn sky news tehran